looking back over nearly 50 years of
training in aikido and tai chi yoga
meditation healing and
many many other hobbies i've
uh what i want to share
today some some thoughts and insights
really
i've given it a lot of time to look and
study
different aikidoka some very well
respected teachers
but we all are getting older and at the
moment the flavor
appears to be perhaps it's always been
this way i don't know but
it appears to be some younger teachers
coming through
and this is a good thing that
we should encourage because they are the
future
we are the past at one time we were the
i remember sato since he's saying to me
when i was in iwan when 1994
tony please keep the obama weapons
safe by developing them
and teaching them and
when he said develop them i didn't
really understand but they
you know change them look at them do
variations
he was giving me permission what a great
honor
that was when he's given us more than
enough to to study without
me developing more i have
developed some but that's another story
what i'd like to talk about today really
is
whether you're you know an established
aikido teacher
as a young student a young teacher
i'd like you to reflect on what you're
trying to achieve
you're trying to copy somebody you
admire
perhaps your own teacher or perhaps a
teacher that is not your teacher but
you've found another one
on youtube you've studied their
different videos the way they do aikido
and
and you really admire them and like them
you may even feel that you can't tell
anyone
else about this they may be private to
you
i remember really being inspired by
nichio
sensing when he was demonstrating
how aikido is like sword work
and the preciseness and accuracy
of the sword applied into his aikido
but somehow that wasn't for me his style
wasn't for me
you know i'm a big person i'm not very
you know
flexible i hope i'm more flexible now
than i used to be
finding not only a teacher that appears
to be
a similar shape and size to yourself
but i'd like to talk about the
practicalities of what i see
and what i think is incorrect
my opinion and my opinion only and you
must
make the judgment yourself
but nowadays i see teachers with
cutting with ken and their back leg is
bent and it's as if when they finish the
cut
they're sitting on a bar store
[Music]
cytosensei corrected me once for this
i copied a teacher and thought he's a
really good
top ranked teacher so he must be correct
and i copied his posture
and psychosis he said to me on a seminar
in germany once
calling me over tony
you look like a duck he said sticking
your backside out like that
well of course straight away i
remembered who the teacher was i was
copying it
and it wasn't psychosensi
and it was very hard for me to undo
what i thought i was doing correctly
i see ken cuts with strange endings
if you are an iwama
aikidoka or an ike
or all the other names that there are
tamiki's and
if you're a shioda senses students
doing yoshinkan
it's difficult who to follow if you can
follow someone who's alive
then obviously that would be better than
someone who's passed on
but these bend back legs on when they're
cutting
or strange like what i call the perfect
posture on ending
is it's more like robotics
in perfection rather than a human being
doing what's
natural a martial art is different
than being a normal standard human being
we do have to learn principles we have
to learn accuracy
we have to learn the technical parts and
why we're doing them
it is a self-defense in my mind and
always has been
therefore the accuracy is very important
what's more important is being able to
move freely
because it's an art of multiple attack
and with multiple attacking you can't be
a stiff
robot unless you think you're that good
that you can stay
you know stiff and accurate while
a few people going to try and pile in
onto you
to do you harm
i hope you know what i'm talking about
look at not just cytoscene see oh
scentsy knee show sensory toe
sensing cuba sensing
the list is endless
study them just watch them you don't
have to um
look at their preciseness and their
techniques
for this particular exercise that i'm
asking you to look at
but they're normal people using their
body
as it was given to them when they were
born
they may straighten their leg this is to
eject power
in the end or stability in the
triangular pose
typos there's a reason why
they have these set stances
but i think what's happening today is
we're getting either
very flowery flamboyant aikido
being demonstrated where there is no
thought of attack it's just harmony
between two people
doing a very nice choreographed set of
aikido moves
i was watching a lady doing a ken cup
that she was copying on a zoom
lesson also the other morning
and i was thinking this doesn't suit
this person's body
they're copying the teacher the male
teacher
but this doesn't so this tall woman's
body
she the good thing
is we all enjoy
our art we all love what we're doing
we think that if we get it correct and
copy
the teacher that's teaching us we will
advance we will go
far beyond what our mental
ability can think of at the time we're
all hoping to be that
perfect akidoka
my advice is become yourself
if you want to follow a teacher find out
why you like them
but if you're in a position that is odd
look at your own video look at what you
look
like if it doesn't look like the person
who's
within yourself how your mind thinks you
should act
then it's wrong trying to
copy somebody that is like trying to fit
on
a jacket that's two sizes too small
or two sizes too large if it doesn't fit
you you shouldn't be doing it
because in a real situation
or even in a situation where you want to
go to great heights
then you need to find out who you are
become yourself
find out how you stand if you've got
a week back or you bend over
you're a bit hunched in the shoulders
these are small things that you can
correct
it means that your posture is not good
but to but to deform
yourself without the word to deform
anyhow
to make yourself a sh into a shape
that isn't suited to your height
size build
then it's wrong and you will never find
the true piece
of the wonderful aikido that ocean sea
gave us
every single person like you know should
be different
because it's their own
to be a robot of somebody else
and to look like somebody else
[Music]
you think that you may feel as good as
what you see
them as it will never happen
trust me on this i've been doing it long
enough to know
so i hope this will help you consider
what i've said
i mean no malice to anybody
but use the body you have
improve it with yoga alexander
techniques
anything that will improve your own
personal posture
but don't try to become something you're
not
use what you were born with thank you
for listening
and i hope you find this of interest
goodbye